each pride month for everybody it's that
beautiful month where corporations
celebrate All Things
lgbtqia plus by sticking rainbow Flags
everywhere not in Iran or Saudi Arabia
because they'll lose money also putting
rainbow flags on buildings it's a bad
look especially if you're throwing gaze
off them Disney have released a pride
Star Wars droid set and all of the
droids come in rainbow colors that's
right because even fictional robots now
shag each other and the worst is R2D2
lives on a desert planet
the sand is gonna get everywhere I don't
like sand that
xc3po see threepio is the gayest robot
of all time C-3PO look like the kind of
robot Who Loved Musicals A white wine
spritzer and a collective works of
Barbara Streisand because Bingo isn't
about Pride Flags or a month or a
community it's about wearing a
figure-hugging gold suit in the desert
and not giving a toss about the heat
because you look fabulous